all I need is experience I need Journeys
stories when you are on your own six
months later in a pub in a Meetup at an
event with a ceso with a head of with an
analyst whatever you can talk about
things other than recruitment other than
cyber security and uh you're engaging
and you have a story from the past so
welcome back to another episode of the
recruitment mentors podcast I'm your
host he mazus and on this week's episode
I was joined by Josh key Josh is one of
the co-founders of a recruitment
business that specializes in the cyber
security space called trient search
before you entered the the recruitment
world you worked in the the military for
six years that's correct yeah climbed
the ranks in in one agency mhm started
your own business within that business Y
is that right yeah Y what year did you
start try then Jan 2020 Jan 2020 a
couple months before lockdown something
that he's really proud of is committing
to his Niche and something that he
really Advocates with his team and we
talk about how all of you listening can
achieve that in your own industry and
why that's important he shares with us
that he doesn't train Recruitment and he
trains commercial Acumen he talks about
what the VCS do what do private Equity
companies do how does a p&l work how do
threat intelligence businesses make
money and really educate his team on the
problems that they solve rather than
being entirely focused on filling jobs
every single day what do I have to be
doing that hopefully in the long run
will mean I can say yeah 70% of my
business comes from refer
I made it on my to-do list my plan yeah
you had your candidate calls you had
your client work etc the first thing I
did every morning at 8:00 was enjoy Josh
welcome to the podcast thank you thanks
for having me looking forward to
breaking down this journey that you've
been on I want to give everyone some
immediate career highlights for Josh so
you you let me know if I get anything
wrong but I think firstly which I'm um
excited just to understand your
experience or at least get your
perspective on but before you entered
the the recruitment world you worked in
the the military for six years that's
correct yeah um so before yeah so you
then entered the the recruitment
industry in
2016 um and then you've been in it ever
since so um climbed the ranks in in one
agency mhm then you uh started your own
business within that business Y is that
right yeah y um and then you started
Trident I want to make sure I get the
year right here what year did you start
Trident Jan 20 J 2020 couple months
before lockdown yeah yeah cool Jan 2020
um so highlighting that first year you
ended up with around four people MH 350
grand net Fe income CU we did NFI didn't
we yeah we did NFI I talk to about title
later that's right and then second year
um ended around eight people 1.25 net
fee income third year 1.8 million net
fee income 14 people fourth we're in the
fourth year now in our fourth year now
in in your fourth year now um I think
you said you're aiming for 2.5 million
net Fe income as a big goal aiming to
get around 25 heads um and then just a
bit more context uh right now it's
around 8020 80 being perm you do around
60% of your business in the M um another
uh and then the 40% in uh us y you do uh
provide different solutions different
products um you know you have contingent
recruitment exclusive but also then you
have I think you call it RPO or like you
know a talent partnership model uh that
you also have that you had some some
really good success with and your world
is everything threat intelligence yes my
personal world yes but we've since
expanded and grown into wider
disciplines across cyber security but um
but yeah Cy security as a whole yeah
okay cool love it so J let's start with
this this million pound question first
then like from your perspective what
what characteristics and traits make up
a highly successful recruiting today's
market good question so I'll try and
stay away from the typical
characteristics that everyone says and
I'll tell you the kind of um what do I
what does it actually take in my opinion
right so what we trying to drive into
everybody at Trident and what do we look
for when we hire people so first one is
we look for people who are obsessed so
an obsession with your job your
community what you're doing and that
doesn't mean you have to work crazy
crazy hours but what I mean by that is
um it's a hard job to switch off right
so the in my opinion the people that
I've seen and my experience and people
we have now who are the top performers
are obsessed with what they do and um
they do work long hours right um there's
no way getting around that but you could
be obsessed 9 to5 but you'd have to be
super disciplined and structured right
so um Obsession for sure um domain
expert so whatever you do whether it's
Finance you just recruit interim
accounts payables or you recruit
pentesters in the cyber security Market
you have to be a domain expert in
exactly what you are recruiting the
people um to the point where you can
come off a briefing call visualizing
exactly what uh that person will be
doing when you get them a job so what
are they doing when they open up the
keyboard laptop day one what are they
doing so domain expert in that sense um
and then uh the one that I think is the
most important for us um and where I see
most recruiters fail is the business
Acumen so what I mean by that is what's
a p&l what's profit what's loss what's
Net versus GP Etc um and we're kind of
that's where we'll come on to it in a
bit about training and stuff but that's
where we train our team on the most not
recruitment not necessarily the Market
but how do you or how do business
operate and therefore and we come into
it in a little bit but um just
understanding how your clients work as a
business and why and the the kind of the
wh ifs and okay if we what's the
implications if we can't find someone so
Obsession the domain expertise and
business Acumen is probably the most
important uh I would say the top three
if you want to Chuck another one in
there I would say you have to be known
for like for something so uh for me you
touched on it a little bit but when I
started Trident I was only doing threat
intelligence within cyber security so
some people would say that's a very
small Market it's a very it's a niche
within a niche but um just drill down
into that and be known for something so
you got the CTI Community here or cyber
threat intelligence I was the person in
the middle So eventually in a very short
space of time everyone was looking
internally at me and its referrals it's
Word of Mouth Etc so um there some great
things yeah yeah I'm excited to go into
the mindset and methodology around the
commercial acument because I think
that's actually a really great tip for
people so I'm excited to go into like
why you you've lent into that and and
what that then means for the team but ju
just before we go into all the
recruitment stuff I I want to make sure
I just ask cuz I'm I'm just genuinely
curious and I know now that in the world
that you're in you do a lot with people
that have served so like it's it's a big
part of your story right so I want to
make sure that we at least touch on that
but I guess all I'm like at all curious
about um I don't have any friends that
that served um and and you often hear I
feel like the um perception can be for
people that it can be difficult to
transition into like the workplace yeah
like post serving whatever that looks
like so I don't want to assume that you
had a challenge with that but that
that's my question really like what what
was it like for Josh entering like the
workplace after working in the Marines
for six years like was that difficult
was that experience like would you mind
just sharing there cuz I know that's
then you actively speak to people and
work with people that previously serve
right so it's a big part of the story
yeah yeah of course I have to uh tell my
story so to speak um we'll take it back
a like a little bit so what do I do in
the Marines um I was heavy weapons um I
served more Maritime so I was doing
counter piracy Somalia Libya um when
colonel gfy in 2014 um so did a lot on
the in the golf of Aiden and and all
around there in the Middle East um but
when I left uh I actually resettled we
call it resettlement right so when you
leave depending on how long you served
and where you served you'll get a like a
resettlement grant so basically a
certain amount of money to then go and
do courses etc etc right so I had I
think £6,000 and I remember quite
vividly talking to one of the guys that
had already left and I was like [__]
you're making a load of money you wear a
Rolex you're wearing some cool clothes
like what do you do and he was like I'm
in it and I was like I'm going to do it
you little did I know I left and I
actually took a pay cut I think I
started I worked at Cisco I started on
like 22k I was like [__] what have I
done um but I went and done like a 12we
course up in Lincoln spent six grand I
was a network and firewall engineer
worked at Cisco for four or five months
and I suppose the only difficulty I had
when I kind of resettled um I was very
lucky was uh I didn't realize that most
of your time as an IT engineer is you're
on your own you're traveling to customer
sites around London you're in a van and
you got your tool bag it's cool when
you're on site and you're in the server
rooms and you're switching out routers
and firewalls and stuff that's cool but
when you're on your own 6 hours a day in
on M25 listening to radio one you want
to blow blow your brains out out cuz I
come from an environment where there's
30 guys all around you all the time
you're on the shooting range you're
playing football you're doing um so then
just sat in a van by myself so that was
probably the difficulty I had and what I
didn't realize at the time was um
firstly your first job when you leave is
not your last job you don't you're not
probably not going to do another six
years in your next job that you go into
um so you have that's a bit of reality
check um but you need to make sure you
have two things around you I think um a
very good uh personal life in terms of
support I had a really good wife um and
we now have a child but um good family
bit of a support network there and also
you got friends that are not in the
military so you have your kind of
Civilian normal life around you that's
not you're always going oh I wish I was
still with the boys and it's like
actually I've got a kind of group of
friends here that I've stayed in touch
with Etc um and then the other bit was
the professional environment that you're
in so how do you get that soft Landing
so when you do leave um it's a bit of a
familiar environment it's not so alien
you're not in a van all day um so that's
where I think people struggle so that's
when I left very quickly and it was a
bit of a ego hit to say [__] I failed
this next job that I've gone into I've
trained for 12 weeks and the employer
that took me on took a bit of a chance
right cuz i' had a marine before and
they were like oh he only he only lasted
like 5 months yeah I was like no that's
not me that's not me like I'm I'm
committed I'm going to do this I lasted
four
months uh so um The Journey uh the
transition show we say um it's obviously
different depending on who you are but
if you have those two things sorted out
your personal professional life good
environment I think so yeah and um
working out what you're going to do is
uh less difficult or it can be more
ambiguous than it is the actual
environment you're in so there's three
we call it the three PS when I talk to
people that are um transitioning into
the real world uh we look at firstly the
people who you going to be working with
the environment the culture then you
look at the purpose what's the purpose
that you're going to have when you move
into that role company Etc and then you
pay so people purpose and pay pay is
always third in my opinion it always is
in life if you're in a good environment
and you're good at your job you're going
to get paid pretty well um but your
purpose and the people that you're
surrounded by is probably the most
important purpose is the probably number
one thing you lose when you leave uh
it's very obvious and it's very black
and white the purpose you have in the
military right most why most people join
um but trying to find a purpose in a in
a normal job uh it's a little bit more
difficult no I appreciate you sharing
that it's that's super interesting and
then just final note on it then because
I think this be useful context why why
is it very common for military Folk to
then end up in cber
security uh a few things one the stat is
we did a survey last year I think it's
like 1800 people uh 51% of cybercity
professionals arex military or or law
enforcement it's crazy right um it makes
my sales and BD a lot easier um but uh
why I suppose uh the guardian mentality
want to protect something want to help
um especially the vulnerable so you
think a lot of ccur people uh or threat
actors and criminals are targeting like
the NHS right right so therefore it's
kind of you're kind of drawn to that um
and also you have like the intelligence
um like section of the army so the incor
um you have government agencies five six
gchq um that do this work already but
just in the public sector so a different
domain um but you can get like people
who have been a chef in the Army right
who then again it's that back to that
Guardian mentality want to help want to
serve um and they're just drawn towards
cyber security so um it's getting better
in the military as well with courses
that are being offered to you as you
leave um that are not just project
management or going to driving or
Logistics or what people think military
are good at um but actually here's a sub
security course to help you transition
and resettle and it's a typical that in
any industry once you get a few people
in that space everyone else is just kind
of magn stories to point out don't you
yeah correct okay I love that awesome I
appreciate you sharing all that so
something that maybe I want to start
with then so um we want to focus on this
trident journey I think something that
you've said to me uh in preparation for
this This and like you're really
passionate about is this domain
expertise and I think you hear that a
lot right you have to be an expert or
from I I feel like in today's market
you're going to make it really hard for
yourself if you're not known for
something or you're not in in a nich you
don't commit to it so I'd love to just
hear your take on like what that
actually looks like do you know what I
mean like to be a domain expert as a
recruiter like what what does that
actually look like is it every single
day I am reading the news about my
industry is it every single day I am
trying to learn just one more thing by
speak from the conversations that I have
like what what does that actually look
like do you know what I mean to become a
domain expert how how do people become
that so one is you have to give a [__]
about what you do right so um you have
to like I said be known for something
which means if you want to kind of get
into the Practical uh like the daily
stuff right so yes it's reading the news
of course it is it's knowing that
yeserday Cisco um intended to buy a
Splunk for $28 billion right and it was
all over LinkedIn so you couldn't miss
it anyway cuz it's such a big
acquisition but um the new news is
really really important then you want to
go right what do people actually do in
their jobs am I genuinely curious about
what you do so um when I'm meeting
people talking to people same across my
team it's what okay so you protect uh I
don't know so let's say I'll give you an
example right I don't mind showing this
because most people know but we built
the security team at EasyJet okay right
so what does it actually mean I could
tell you what it actually means when
you're on your flight uh to IA with the
with the girls um that the threat actors
in North Korea don't try and take down
your play and put you in the water right
that's a pretty like real world like
situation so if you genuinely care about
that kind of stuff then talking to the
security team easj you're like hey so
what's going on and they can't tell you
everything but um just being curious
about how they protect it who's hitting
or targeting the airlines um will help
just genuinely build your knowledge and
then if you have a team of 25 recruiters
all with that kind of mindset everyone's
just sharing stuff right as soon as we
come in on a Monday morning people like
right what's going on what happened this
weekend who's been hit who's been
attacked what's happening in Vegas uh
who's hit the MGM Grand and then you
look at like okay the MGM Grand let's
use that as an example um I'm talking to
people that I know are actually
responding to the incident they're in
Vegas now there's 12 of them and they're
like the MGM is not the only Casino
that's been hit and then you look at the
news it's just MGM mg because it's the
biggest name right Caesars Etc there's
30 cinos out there that have been
whacked wow right so and and then it
says MGM losing $4 million a day and
you're like yeah they are what about the
other ones combined it's $22 million a
day they're losing and like if you
genuinely care about that cuz I think
that's super interesting right and I'm
like right now how
and then next you go kind of layer
deeper than that I'm in WhatsApp groups
where it's just full of cesos so SE
Suite of the kind of security World um
who are just talking about that and then
next thing you know I've got like a
GitHub repository um which is like a
thing called like notepad on your uh
laptop um the thragg has actually uh
sent a message to uh the public so to
speak but you won't see it in the news
on BBC it's only on like GitHub
repositories and um I'm in that group
and you read it and you're like [__]
like the thrag is actually talking about
how they did it w and they're like we
gave them a heads up we told them X they
didn't respond blah blah blah blah blah
we still have control of XXX um so if
you're in those circles and I don't go
in there with the idea or mindset that
hey I'm a head hunter uh can I help you
build your teams it's just I want to be
in the middle of the community and
understand what the [__] going on um
so I I opened it this morning and people
are talking about like what's going on
with some Microsoft Technologies like
co-pilot and how AI is affecting it and
how they've implemented it in their
teams um and then I go I sort of talk to
my te like guys did you know this and I
was like [__] I didn't know that next
thing you know the team are then pinging
in more kind of Articles and news and
then all day all you do is hear them
talking to candidates and clients about
that um so it's just kind of like almost
like infectious when you're in that
environment so I don't know if it ANW
your question but no no that I think
that there's you know like you said like
be commit one you have to care about
what you do and be genuinely interested
in that like you said like really commit
to consuming content like you know
making sure that you're on a diet of
content that is in in your industry
right so are you scrolling and consuming
you know what just like just [__] or are
you actually consuming stuff that could
actually be really interesting and
helpful in line with what you do and
then you said yeah just like commit to
being really curious so how long does
that take you know if I if I do you know
what I mean because I think sometimes
people can think oh I'm never going to
get there or I'm never going to truly be
a domain expert so like when you hire
people clearly this is something that's
really important to you like how do you
fra how do you frame that up are you
saying like look like you'll you'll be
as competent as I am within six months
if you have this approach like how long
does that take uh I don't know if it's a
specific kind of period of time um
because it's the more you put in the
more you get out except like kind of
cliche right but um in our environment
it's faster than normal because again
it's infectious and you only have to be
there and be a sponge and it's kind of
just even like subliminally you're just
hearing it in the back of like
conversations over there um but if I had
to put a number on it it's two three
years good for people to hear yeah cuz
it like what and then look at the kind
of the drop off of recruiters after 9
months 12 months into job and they're
like this isn't what I thought it was
I'm not making the commission I was
going to make and then you're like you
know the old uh the guy in the mining
cave and he's like stops and he's like
this close before Edge and that one um
that's like genuinely I see that all the
time in in in this space not just in
cyber but um yeah I would say two three
years the first year is just you giving
all in it's just input input input right
and you're going to get little out let's
be very Frank you might make on a 30k
base you might make 50k which is still
good right um comparative to other
Industries but um to be a genuine domain
expert and to put yourself in the middle
of the communities hosting the events
being on stage talking to people um and
have the knowledge to be able to hold a
conversation yeah it's well over a year
yeah no I appreciate you sharing that
because that's good for people to to
know and then just final thing on it
yeah are you saying that cuz I like my
you tell me what you think but my
opinion is Josh isn't going to be um
you're not going to be as competent as a
c so no and that isn't your aim here y
you're and like yeah people don't pay
you to be as competent as a ceso right
however like it is absolutely your job
as a you know industry expert recruiter
to really commit to understand um and be
in the middle of those people where
actually the best thing that you can do
is one yeah understand what goes on in
these um people's worlds to the best of
your ability but also to say be in the
middle of say like hey I spoke to five
cesos today these are the things that
they're sharing me like what do you
think of that like the and like be that
you know be that exchange of information
but I think sometimes people I don't
know if you found this but sometimes
people think that in order for them to
become a domain expert they have to be
as competent as the people that they're
placing or working with but that isn't
what you're saying right you're just
saying that you need to commit to being
at the epicenter of like your world and
to be able to be in a room and listen
and understand but you're never going to
be as competent these as these people
yeah yeah correct uh if you could have
50% of of the knowledge of the people
that you're hiring or hiring for job
well done right but you add the business
Acumen and we'll come on to the
commercial side uh to that plus our
business model right we hire 30y olds
who have had a life before right I don't
care what that life looks like all I
need is experience I need Journeys
stories and so then when you are on your
own six months later in a pub in a
Meetup at an event with a ceso with a
head off with an analyst whatever you
can talk about things other than
recruitment other than cyber security
and uh you're engaging and you have a in
the like from the past so um yeah that
really helps but you don't need and and
you have to accept you're never going to
be at that level if you want to be then
go into the industry we've had two or
three people leave our agency we've
given them certifications along the way
which we continue to do now um knowing
that sometimes we do lose people to the
industry because it's so ex interesting
and they're like [__] I want to be in
that all day every day um but if you
think you're going to be at that level
as of AO then you need to have a real
reality because I think sometimes people
confused with that yeah yeah yeah okay
so let let's talk about cuz again this
is something clearly you've doubled down
on and I don't
think many people have really
highlighted that it's something they
intentionally do so let's talk about it
let's talk about why do you and your
co-founder really put a lot of emphasis
on developing commercial Acumen because
I'll be honest I have interviewed people
where they've said that's important but
they they necessarily haven't said like
we actively intentionally like help Josh
the recruiter understand how our clients
make money and understand the p&l and
understand the true problems that we
solve and these things so when you say
we you know we train our people on
Commercial Acumen like one what does
that actually mean and then two like why
do you do that and what are the the
positive impacts the net positives that
you found that then means when you know
your team are recruiting yeah yeah cool
so uh two ways we do it in terms of
training uh so one is we actually or
actively um ask some of our clients to
come into the office so we build
commercial teams for cyber security
vendors so software vendors right
thinking maafe of the world um we will
ask a vpf sales or a cro hey can you
come in can you speak to my kind of go
to market team and explain to them what
the impact of us hiring an ACC exec for
you is um and then the way that kind of
uh and then we do the other bit of
training which is hey guys this is a
venture capital firm this is a private
Equity company this is this is a p&l
this is net verse growth I show them our
pnl I so look and they look at and go oh
they fall asleep right because it's just
line items of a spreadsheet and they
don't give a [__] about that right but
what I'm trying to get him to visualize
is when and this is the end goal right
when a company that we recruit for let's
say it's a big it could be an Israeli
software vendor that want to break into
the US right so when that um company are
in a board meeting end of month meeting
right you got the CFO CEO cro whatever
um the CFO looks at that and they go on
the on on the PowerPoint they go holy
[__] Trident we spent 50 Grand with them
this month but then the C is who's your
internal sponsor right think like that
goes yeah yeah yeah that's fine I know
it's a lot of money on paper and as a
line item but they found four accoun
execs this year accumulatively that
those four have made $2.8 million for us
this year and the guy goes keep using
them how can they get more people in so
if my team can visualize our clients in
those boardrooms that's what you are
right you're genuinely just a cost right
but if we can go we are but we do like
end of quarter reviews with our clients
and we say hey we found someone at the
start of July how they getting on I've
spoken to them they love it they've just
closed their first deal 800k deal with
Kelloggs whatever um so they're settling
in well they're doing well he's like
yeah yeah I was like do you need anymore
because they're Revenue generators the
more I can find for you the the the the
more money you're going to make the
better you look as the the leader of the
sales team now attribute that to like a
technical team let's go back to EasyJet
example if we're building a team of
security operations analysts so people
that monitor and sit there and look at
the networks and make sure that there's
no malicious threat actor trying to get
in and they can like um they get alerts
when they are in ETC um I can speak to a
sock analyst uh after I don't know
they've been there a couple of months go
hey how you getting on they're like yeah
I love it blah blah blah blah blah Tak
for lunch and then they go yeah but I I
was like but what what impact have you
made since you've joined and then they
say well actually I blocked six
malicious threats coming from China um
and therefore that meant that we are we
had no downtime we're a trading firm
that means that we can continue to
trading blah blah blah blah blah right
so you can kind of attribute it to both
the technical side of security that we
recruit so the defensive teams but also
the sales teams um even software
developers that we recruit U I've built
X since we've done I've relase a new
product a new feature and that meant
that we could actually then take it to
Market and our commercial teams are
selling it um so you can see the genuine
value and then when you take it to
another customer or a new client and
doing kind of new BD which we can come
on to in a bit how we do it you can kind
of approach a new vpa sales and go hey I
know you know Steve the VPS sales of
that firm ask him I played six people
there this year and they've done XXX in
millions um so it's almost too hard for
them to say no so it sounds like then I
love that by the way so it sounds like
then what you're really encouraging your
people to do is which I think sometimes
recruiters can end up being laser
focused on is just I placed Josh in a
job right and that that's like that's
what you see whereas what you're talking
about is like hey guys um you know what
I'm going to help you understand here is
truly the impact that you're making by
finding these people and putting these
people in these seats and you're doing
that by one which I absolutely love the
idea of you know bringing in your
clients to talk about you know the story
of by you helping us get this person
this is what it's resulted in um and
this is what it means but you're also
then you know equipping people with the
knowledge which I really rate because a
lot of people um don't understand I
think it be should be something in in
like schools it's talk about do you know
what I mean in terms of like p&l all
those things and I really like that that
you know thinking about when that that
hiring manager or when that person that
you've got a relationship with is asked
Josh why why have we spent that money
with with X agency that you know that
they're going to be able to answer that
because of the conversations that you
have and to be able to really visualize
that or even understand that that's the
sort of conversations that they're going
to have is like really important right
but then like you said by developing
that I'm then asking those you know
really smart questions of like yeah like
what impact have you had on the business
rather than just like are you enjoying
your job how's it going right and let's
kind of take a few steps ahead and the
impact of my team they grow as people so
like you said at schoool we don't learn
about interest rates debt Finance Etc
right which is obviously an everyday
occurrence in our life um so if my team
can walk away and I know full well
people won't be here for 10 years right
they won't be here when we exit in seven
years whatever but if I know full well
that you've left and you're part of our
alumni down the line and you go do you
know what I learned how to be a better
recruiter I made some money I did good I
made an impact but more importantly I
grew as a person I've learned more about
life um and just general business and it
equips them if they want to go set up a
competitor and great do it right won't
be very happy but that's life and that's
part of the business but if it means
that they grow as humans the other side
and it took me years to learn that or
think like that um and I owe a lot to my
old CEO he brought me into the boardroom
probably two years into my recruitment
uh sort of um uh career uh when I set up
the business internally after doing it
um and I have a lot to thank for him for
that CU I was sitting and listening to
conversations all these old white men
just talking about business p&l costs
why and listen to the CFO talk get and
his View on it cuz he didn't really care
about how many people we recruited he
cared about the bottom line Top Line uh
in and out right so if I could expose
our team to that as quickly as possible
even if they're 27 years old or 40 years
old um I think it just goes a long way
in their personal life yeah no I agreed
and also then like you just said which
will ke to uh get your um just Journey
with it now but then like the stories
that you then tell your customers and
potential customers is just entirely
different right you're talking about not
the we play like this uh we worked at
vjet and we placed all these people
you're saying we did that but also
because we found those people they were
able to um you know prevent 30 different
attacks from like do you know what I
mean you're them telling those stories
and that's just like worlds aart from
saying hey Josh like yeah I I can get
people for you like yeah I can find
these people that do that rather than
saying hey I can find you free account
Executives and this is the impact that
you can expect they can make cuz this is
what's happened uh with ex customer so I
love that let let's talk about because
it's something that you know people
always interested interested in and you
know want to hear people's experience
with but you know you've continued to go
on an upward trajectory uh NFI wise but
do you mind sharing like what has been
you know consistently uh the most
effective way for Trident to um
consistently win good quality business
and and you know on the client
acquisition side like what what does
that look like for you guys what's been
the most effective channels I can
imagine you know know we're talking
about you guys being completely
committed to being domain experts and
all that that's had a obviously huge
impact and I know you do things like
podcast and networking events but like
yeah what what's been the most
consistent way of you acquiring good
quality business and and consistently
doing that cuz that that's key to you
guys growing the NFI so uh news flash we
don't coold call okay my team don't Co
call right um there's a number of
reasons why um but you try and pick up
the phone to us see sir hey I've got a
good security analyst here for you just
just on the market within budget they're
like come on like I'm trying to protect
the business here if I'm want to phone
to you as a Head Hunter and we get
hacked I get fired right so there's
other ways and channels to that person
um so um you mentioned or you touched on
a few things there uh for us the most
important parts are yes your domain
expertise and stay Niche super super
Niche right and it's really difficult to
tell especially a rookie recruiter or
someone who's got two years from another
agency that goes oh hey Josh I know I do
um uh sock Recruitment and I build msps
um but they want me to recruit a
pentester can I can I do it I know I'll
feel it I'll work later I won't do it in
hours I won't po I'm like no and it's
really difficult right cuz like yeah but
that'll make me a 12K Fe which will make
me two and a half Grand commission I'm
like no and it's really hard to
especially at the start to go trust me
follow the process and it will work out
for you um that's uh but that's a
consistent message that we send from our
from me and Charlie down to our heads of
departments down to seniors to
Consultants Associates um even our
marketing is super consistent in terms
of like being really really Niche um and
uh that's a message where it's not it's
not convincing them it's just like trust
me that it's worked stay in your Niche
right so Niche is yeah definitely won um
this year we've really really doubled
down we did it a lot last year but we
hired Lotty who's our marketing manager
who's epic um and we spend as much money
as possible and time and resource on
pushing the brand out there doing these
networking events um but then the events
are all well and good and we do lots of
like EXA search kind of or exact round
taes and that's all well and good but
then what's the followup what's the
purpose what's the point point this
isn't just a piss up for load of cesos
who just want to like drink on our free
bartab um it's what change are you
putting in place off the back of this
Meetup so the first one would have been
about diversity and it's like not
necessarily just gender but it could be
neurodiversity it could be veterans or
whatever it be then what LTE will do and
what whoever runs the event will be
right let's do a follow-up report let's
get it out to everyone and three months
later what have you done what action
have you put into place um so those
networking events are really really
really key for us and then um and then
it's just referrals so we've got quite a
good name quite a good brand because we
spend so much money on it and we spend
so much time and effort on tter but um
almost I think I looked yesterday it's
like 88% of our business is in inbound
wow so and there have been challenges
about with that this year right because
it's been a tough year economically Etc
so um we've had to flip that uh into
more outbound stuff and to really push
the message out a little bit more um and
do more outbound um engagements but um
but yeah so I'd say super super Niche
and like actually live it as well cuz I
know so many recruiters are like yeah
I'm Niche and then you see them post
something else and they come to
interview for me and they're like yeah
I'm really Niche and I pull up their
LinkedIn I go what's that then they're
like oh well it's just like a a really
good client that wanted and they only
give it to me exclusively um the
networking the marketing the events um
and then the last piece that we do uh we
started launching it I launched one
pre-o which is called the waloo Cyber
Club which you saw we host on Wednesday
uh a group of 700 uh military and law
enforcement veterans um who work in
cyber security in the UK so we had an
event last on Wednesday 100 people
turned up and it's um we give a little
talk but it's all about uh the two
things the two kind of similarities
everyone has veterans in cyber but about
seeing old friends and just networking
and just um having a beer with people
right and in again a very familiar
environment for people what that does
though um is that again it puts us at
the center of the of the industry and
the communities so we've launched our
sales engineering one we've launched CTI
one we've launched Microsoft Security
One um and the idea is we've got closed
LinkedIn groups we've got closed Discord
group um and sometimes it's not meetups
some of the Microsoft security guys
don't want to meet up that's cool that's
fine you don't do that what we're do
instead is maybe like like a technical
online virtual um Capture the Flag or
something like that so um the community
is really important we call them the
clubs um but again it puts us right at
the center of the industry this podcast
is proudly partnered with vin Cherry the
all-in-one recruitment agency software
that over 20,000 recruiters trust daily
we're also partnered with the
award-winning oneup sales sales and
motivation platform that enables you to
maximize the potential of your teams we
love partnering with both of these
organizations because they share our
mission in helping you get the most out
of your people and your business you can
get exclusive offers because you listen
to this podcast and get up to 10% off
the usage price forever use a link in
the show notes to get your hands on that
let's get back to the episode so yeah
you've worked really hard then I mean
88% inbound that's a lot hi right yeah
yeah um and would you are you including
referrals in that yeah yeah yeah yeah of
course talk talk to us a bit like talk
to us a bit about that if I want to get
to that
position you know like what are going to
be the the biggest levers that I can you
know lean into leverage in in the long
term that's going to help me get to that
point like if I want to get to a point
where nearly 90% of my business is
either coming referral inbound or that
you might have just uh spoken about it
but like you know if I'm working towards
that what is it the what are the main
levers I need to you know keep pulling
each day from you know what I need to
make sure my teams are doing what I'm
doing to really be able to get to that
point you've mentioned marketing but as
an actual individual recruiter what can
I do every single day that you know
we're playing the long game here you're
talking about two years three years for
domain expertise you're not talking
about 3 months and 6 months what every
single day what do I have to be doing
that hopefully in the long run will mean
I can say yeah 70% of my business comes
from referral okay so uh when we first
started Trident I was on my own uh
January until Charlie joined me the
co-founder um just got 6 weeks eight
weeks after got went into lockdown um so
I made it on my to-do list my plan yeah
you had your candidate calls you had
your client work etc the first thing I
did every morning at 8:00 was and this
is very rudiment rudimentary and very
basic was just repost a news article
about cyber security as simple as that
right get your name on LinkedIn so when
people are because it's force a habit
right even the professionals don't use
Instagram anymore they're St LinkedIn
everyone's on the toilet in the morning
LinkedIn LinkedIn LinkedIn so what how
do they see Josh key on their on the
thing and they're liking it and sharing
it if you can go one better and start
writing your own articles and things and
great but more importantly every single
morning 8:00 get something out there so
create your content and it just becomes
a part of you it's a habit um and it
builds your own personal brand espe your
personal marketing um you can develop
that like I said into content and and
other bits but um and then what we try
and get everybody to do which is hey you
are a domain expert in new business for
xdr companies in cyber security in
America okay cool that's your Niche
within a niche now go build a podcast
series with it go do a our Trident talks
uh not quite as popular as this one but
um go and build a series work with our
marketing team and what that will allow
you to do is connect with the very
senior people in the industry um to uh
obviously invite them on and it's a
conversation that's not recruitment so
um the two main things that we almost
Focus everybody on that just joins us
from day one is your personal marketing
and then go build your podcast series
and you might not be that good at
interviewing people that's totally fine
we'll practice we we'll coach you we'll
teach you through it but the whole point
is is that it gives you a reason to be
in someone's inbox and uh whether it's a
LinkedIn email um other than recruitment
so you'll see it all the time we'll have
rookies that just join and then we'll
say right your podcast series is going
going to go live November 1st it's going
to end end of November I need eight
episodes from you you've got two months
to get all of those eight people
recorded and um invited Etc um so but
what I'm really doing there is I'm
asking you to just to go and network
with the very senior people in your
industry and just treat them all like
candidates they're not clients don't put
them on this massive pedestal up here
and cuz what I've seen before and what
we used to do in my old agency was you
only do candidates for six months
because you're new you're not allowed to
talk to a client yet all happens then is
that the the client's going up here
totally top of the mountain they're like
then they got to start talking to
clients like holy [__] like he's up
there or she's up there so treat
everyone like a candidate and but use
that podcast series that try to talks
not not always that but that's our kind
of medium if you like to network with
very senior people in in your industry
and just befriend them and just get to
know them and be genuinely curious and
interested um and then that will that
will there that's how we build referrals
so very senior candidates in the
industry um that's been easier to do
this year than ever before because there
are more senior people on the market
because the economy is so [__] um
especially in the US right every day I'm
talking to VPS of sales and they are
good people they hit their number and
it's sometimes it's not necessarily
their fault um they're not the B players
C players they're still good a players
but might be like a company restructurer
or what whatever um you put it down to
but that this year is I think will
rocket ship us next year because we've
got all those all those conversations
right and again they're not always about
Recruitment and is it is it key there
just to make sure yeah do all those
things but then make sure that every VP
of sales understands what Trident do and
and the problems that you solve and what
goes back to that boardroom conversation
right yeah of having business
conversations so when they say oh I
worked at this company I'm like okay
cool what do they do and and they be
like oh we were a um a tax surface
monitoring company I'm like okay call
but who did you help and then what was
the impact to your customers and then
you go deeper into the conversation
about business not well what was your
number what was your quota Etc so then
we're like well that's what we do at
Trident right we go super deep into the
business conversation yes we need domain
expertise and I know what our tax
service monitoring platform does but
then I know they're competitors I'm like
well your your competitors do it that
way so how come you did it this way and
then you start having like deeper
conversations with them and then they
come off the phone going hopefully going
[__] that person knows what they're
talking about um and we barely spoke
about recruitment
and then um the other thing that we do
post that kind of conversation is we'll
set very clear expectations so you're
not not going to hear from me ever again
but what I will do is have weekly
check-ins with you just touch base even
if I've got nothing to help you in terms
if you're looking for a job that is um
we're very very big on just constant
touch points of everybody so um yeah
love that so let let's go into because I
know you're on a real journey here to
get to a point where you know there's
some sort of business event right for TR
yeah so I think you know from what I
took from our um prep call in this is
what you see is a quite valuable part of
that journey is this other product line
the RPO piece right cuz sure you know
that's more like guaranteed recurring
Revenue um and that hopefully will give
you you know even more chance of getting
a better mple or you know um more
Equitable value in your business or
Enterprise Value so talk to us a bit
about that when did you start that
product how long have you um been
providing that product and then I'll
I'll hit you with some questions on
what's been hard about it the
conversations I've had with people that
have experienced that like how long have
you been doing that that product and
service about two years two years yeah
not long and then just to frame out to
people typically what that looks like is
um I know it may vary but the the Crux
of it it's a company will agree with you
for a minimum term that they're going to
pay you x per month to uh provide X
deliverables X number of people I don't
know you know the Ty deliverables and
then I think you said it might vary but
that's the core of it so you got
guaranteed Revenue there they got
guaranteed resource and then I think you
mentioned that per placement you might
also charge something that might not be
for everyone but you might charge and
I'm assuming that's going to be reduced
and then yeah there's it's a period of
time so it's like guaranteed uh like
just talk us a bit about the Crux of
that product yeah yeah so uh your spot
on so yeah we will charge uh typical
customer um that will Target give you
some very practical examples a 50 person
software company so security software
company just had 15 million in series a
funding M and uh they very founder Le
everything founder Le sales founder Le
hiring founder Le software building
everything right so then um we'll come
in even through the Venture Capital firm
that's funded them um they want their Ro
ASAP right they want a real big multiple
return in three four years um
particularly if they're a private Equity
Firm um but um then they'll go right
bring Trident in and will'll liaz with
the founder or directly or or through
the funer um and then we'll say right
we'll be inhouse Talent team we could
also do a HR and your people function
for you as well so I built HR is's and
things like that um we have a very clear
it's called like a people framework so
it's acronym is source and we can go
into detail later maybe put it in the
link and I'll share it for free I don't
mind giving it to anyone um and what
that does is it puts in step every
single um kind of like uh uh I suppose
like an ATS hris Etc like sort of thing
in place um for where you are as a
business on your journey so it's like a
score card
yeah like almost like a checklist right
but things that a Founder would not
think about right so how do you build
programs with universities how do you
build relationship with them to get more
graduate software engineers in later
down the line so there are things that
are immediate and there are things that
may be further down the line so you need
to get your Linkin page up and running
all that kind of stuff right so we'll
put that people framework in place uh as
part of the service we'll charge them a
set fee every month M and then uh we'll
charge them a percentage A reduced
percentage of every placement that we
make
right what we found the challenges of
that were especially the first one we
only did a set we only did a set fee
every month so hey you pay us $20,000 a
month what we found be like as many
deliverable like as many people yeah
yeah yeah and we'll say hey we'll get
you two people a month for that what we
found was um our consult our recruiters
were less engaged and inclined to go and
build uh put five people in there um
because that won't be their sole job
right because it's only $20,000 a month
I've got probably five six other clients
over here that want like a couple of
people a month Etc so I what we found
found was um without that percentage of
every placement the consultant after a
couple of deals in that client or after
a couple of placements were just losing
interest because they're like well the
next ones are just free um so um I had a
very honest conversation with that
client and that's when we introduced a
small percentage single figure
percentage of each deal and it's just an
incentivization so I could take that
consultant and say right those clients
over there are now with another
consultant you're now solely focused on
this but then the client will commit for
18 months and what that 18 months is all
about is typically when you get series a
and just talking sort of the IAL that
$15 million is due for like the runway
will be 18 months and then kind of 12
months into that they then spend the the
last 6 months uh raising series B um
depending on how the performance of the
business is ETC not always the case
because they might have some revenue
from customers but um that's why we'll
go right 18 months we'll get you through
your series a you'll get your few first
few customers use cases Etc um but uh
it's tough It's um it's tough to win
because you have to convince that
founder to spend a lot of money with you
and not build an in-house Talent team
why wouldn't they do that um and it's
typically because they don't have the
expertise um or they they then get the
whole of trident to lean on if the
volume kicks up um but we're on one now
in the US uh in Tennessee and we feel
like such a part of the business they've
shipped us laptops we've got all the
t-shirts the hats we've got their bloody
Mouse mats everything we've been over
there a number of times we're in their
Comm um XCOM so their um board meetings
and things like that and they treat us
like an employees we're on their teams
chats everything um that so we're so
immersed in business so it's not the RPO
or MSP model that people know of like
resource Solutions at Microsoft um we
don't use Outsource agencies when we're
on site um so it's it's really I think
it's the my most favorite part of
recruitment or the favorite kind of
method or means because my Consultants
when they are internal they learn so
much more than just putting people bums
on seats they learn why they they have
to speak to the stakeholders and also
then when they go back to kind of
contingent recruitment they they can
kind of empathize with the talent
acquisition manager on site I know why
you're not giving me feedback I I can
visualize the kind of up the chain
communication and probably why you're
not getting feedback on CVS and stuff so
so it's a couple things and then because
I want to make sure we touch on then how
you've really commited to building
infrastructure this year as so just
quickly on this then because I think
people find this interesting um so
firstly what what have you found to end
up being like the
typical uh contract length for these
things what has ended up being I know I
know it's it varies but like if you were
to look at the all the different ways
that you've done that with different
companies yeah is it six months is it 12
months is it three months what's ended
up being like typically where you know
where people have ended up committing
for X period of Time Out Of Interest
yeah so the initial commitment is always
three months okay yeah with um a month
break CLA like a four we break CLA uh
we've had uh some finish at s months
last year but that's because the firm
brought by private ex so completely out
of our hands we got one now that's
committed for 18 months okay so the
contract is 18 months um and if they uh
pull out before that then we charged a
full 18 months um so used normally start
three months yeah three months is
initial engagement um the first one we
ever done was two weeks right I said
look you've never and they've never
worked with us so you've never worked
with us here's a two we almost like a
try before you buy and it's it's two
weeks so um we're still on that contract
now okay right okay that's interesting
and then uh just so we understand what
would you say is the main reason why
people are buying that what's like the
main problem that you're uh cuz is it is
it cost or now do you know what I mean
cuz I feel like some people can just
lean into like this is way cheap like if
you do it this way it's way cheaper Josh
like what move that but I don't feel
like that's necessarily the leading
indicator engage it's not cheaper right
it's not there are three kind of things
that uh a Founder internal HR will look
at right it's the speed of higher the
volume of higher and the cost of higher
right typical three things again this
comes down to the business Acumen of
understanding the business right and
what uh motivates them spe the cost of
higher is going to be expensive so
forget about that so we need the
customers who have just committed to the
investors and said we're going to build
a 50 person team in the US so we need
the speed of higher and we need the
volume of higher so as soon as possible
so the reason why they come to us is
then they go well these guys can do it
because they've got the communities and
the market reach we're just going to go
straight for them and it might cost us
800k and not 450 if we have an internal
team but we've got almost guaranteed
we've got use cases and we let them talk
to old clients hey ask the vph HR there
what we did or the founder there what we
did um so that's interesting yeah so
it's let yeah it's those two things
because I think sometimes people that is
a perception that it's like cheaper but
actually what you're saying is like
actually it's not but we can solve these
two problems for you is we can get you
the people that you need that your
investors are going to expect you to to
have a lot more quicker and like you
just said like by you know uh partnering
with you instantly we get access to all
your network and all those types of
things but what's the conflict if or
what's the problem if you um if you
don't get us on board to higher that
volume and the quality as fast as
possible um you run out of Runway so you
because you're the companies overheads
uh you've only got 18 months right you
need people in as soon as possible
because sales people take time to ramp
up um so um yeah the investors are there
encouraging you just spend you spend it
sustainably and wisely but you need to
spend it to get people in that's the
whole point of getting investment so you
can build the product release new
features on it and go and build a
commercial team to take it to Market um
and then just final two points one how
do you how you structure commission for
that like what does that look like same
it yeah we don't change it whether that
changes in the future I don't know um we
have so basically so if I so just so we
understand that so like if I sold uh
would it would it only if I sold it or
would it depend on who sold it so like
let's say I sold to cyber security firm
thre month partnership it was $20,000 a
month and then it was 8% per placement
so you're saying what unlocks my
commission is like so 20 grand goes next
to my name on the board straight away
for for that is each months and then
each time I do a placement that adds up
and then I just get a percentage of that
like you normally would yeah yeah so we
pay I'll tell you our commission scheme
we pay 20% flat on everything it's
quarterly but we pay monthly but resets
quarterly um anything over 45k in that
quarter so you're a 180 biller it's 30%
right once you've hit your Target in the
year it's 40% flat right right so we've
got people hitting their target July 1st
this year and me and Charlie like holy
[__] um that was a mistake but the whole
point of that and the reasoning behind
it is um it's just all profit you set a
Target on someone's performance and
capability but also you need to make a
profit of someone right typically in
London a recruiter cost you 10K a month
easy some just bit below bit above
whatever but typically 10K a month so
you go right consultants in the in
London need to make 120 so if we give
everyone a Target 150 that 30k is just
profit why do we want to keep it in the
bank give it to give it back to them so
if you do 150 anything over that's 40%
plus your salary you're typically taking
home about 61 to 70% of every deal you
do um so those Partnerships yeah like
would go against M that would be like
what I'd put yeah it's all yours it's
all yours and and like some people are
going whoa you're crazy like you can't
keep I'm like why why not give it back
to them and also typically these rpos or
Talent l a service models are harder
yeah you're always on especially if
you're doing us you got to do that's the
thing like I have heard people say like
you said you speak all the stakeholders
there's positives to that but then
there's negatives to that that they
expect you can't hide right you're the
person there you have to deliver so and
then just the final thing on that then
what because normally when I speak to
people that do that the the the one of
the big common challenges is then like
capacity and like figuring that out cuz
do you know what I mean I don't know if
you run into that cuz it's like you can
sell that but it's like [__] I've now
got deliver yeah yeah yeah uh no luckily
we haven't come into that yet okay one
of our clients I have one consultant on
it and she's doing between five and
eight highes a week wow right what perm
or contract perm M it's unbelievable
right but they are uh we've got the
process using that framework slick it's
super slick the only time it takes a
little bit longer in an extra stage is
when we're hiring a SE Suite or VP there
so from April to now she's Tak that
company from 40 to 170 heads that's M
right what's his framework then the
source thing the source yeah yeah yeah
what does that stand for uh setup
outcome I can't remember I'll put it
into the thing but it's and then we go
into each under each one it's super
detailed um in uh like the kind of
actionable points you need to take under
each acronym so the whole so the whole
point of that is we're going to
implement source which is our framework
to help you become effective employers
and hirers of people and the hardest
thing there is um particularly if
they're a little bit more mature is no
no no we always do four interview stages
and you're like yeah but you do that uh
or they want to do a HR interview as
well if there's a HR person you're like
but what's the point of us so it takes
time to build that trust you going have
to share that with me then share that
because 100% you can use it put okay so
as we come to the end here talk to me
about um infrastructure like the the
journey that you've been on right cuz I
think you shared with me you've uh so
your responsibility typically is been
like Finance operations Talent running
like half um half of the team yeah but I
think you said you know you're building
everything for um exit or like you know
you know you're building the Enterprise
value of your business right and I said
what what does that mean so I think you
said this year correct me if I'm wrong
you've had a people manager marketing
Finance you've got a chairman who's from
your industry I believe um board advisor
and this is all to you know have these
things now so you can grow into the
infrastructure that you need to be a 25
30 plus person company y talk to us just
a bit about some of the the key things
there and and why this infrastructure
bit is so important yeah yeah cool
absolutely so uh the bit bit of context
for you so from since we start in 2020
we've doubled in headcount and revenue
every year granted it was three years
right but um at the start of this year
we were I think 14 heads and we're doing
1.8 million in just fees I think it's
about 3 million total with contract
Revenue Etc um but we were like almost
like a jenger block we're getting fatter
at the top and at the bottom which is
your foundations talk about back office
operations it was just getting it just
didn't sort of grow it all on me and
Charlie um so we were like well we're
going to fall over at some point right
and we're going to keep grow and then
what happens is you're almost a conveyor
belt of Consultants you lose them as far
as you can gain them right so um it was
this year was we'll grow in Revenue even
though the econom is [__] um but we'll
steadily grow in head count but more
importantly we'll F get our finance
manager people manager marketing manager
we'll promote people internally to heads
of and we coach and develop them which
we've got now um which means that me and
Charlie can focus on other things like
developing new offices and growing Etc
um and uh and we do a lot of BD me and
Charlie but um yeah so that was super
super important because I've seen it
many times where companies just fall
over uh because they haven't got that
still all founder Le all back office
right or it's outsourced and um our
finance was outsourced for three years
and I thought that was uh it was doing
right you're bringing someone in house
who then goes wow like where's the
process where's the like where's the
structure where's your end of months and
um cuz you're so focused on just getting
Revenue in the door right um so that's
been like a godsend for us and the idea
was was those three key hires they're
smarter than us like way smarter at what
they do they're unbelievable you go into
a meeting room with our marketing
manager and it's like don't say anything
stupid don't say anything stupid because
she's so so smart right um so that's
what the plan has been this year we've
hired a chairman I think when's this
going out uh be like towards end of
October mid October fine so I can
announce it because it comes out next
week uh so Mike susong is his name uh ex
Ranger ex CIA set up one of the first
cyber security companies in 2007 sold it
to firey for just under $300 million uh
like the OG of cyber right absolute
Legend of a bloke super humble really
under the radar um don't know what he's
seing in us but he's joining us as a
chairman and he's helping us uh kind of
really press into the US so he's got all
the contacts in the Venture Capital
World um and uh we officially launched
our us uh function first of September we
got two more people joining us from
competitors um and we're out there in a
couple of weeks but the point that's
bringing some of that in is that's a lot
of clout right to bring him in with his
background then hopefully clients would
be like well they're obviously doing
something right if he's put his brand in
his name against us so yeah that was why
it's so important um we just on that
just quickly like yeah there's got to be
he's got to be there's got to be some
sort of commercial interest surely like
if you given an X to that person Equity
yeah and then he sits on your board then
100% um and equity in the business yeah
and we give him we give him part ship
agreements of any kind of doors he opens
for us no it doesn't need money right
but um I think it's only fair right get
some skin in the game um and then he's
fully committed to us um I've seen it
where board advisers join where there's
no commission there's no equity there
and it doesn't work because we you don't
take them seriously and they don't take
you seriously so no one comes prepared
to board meetings board meetings don't
happen um so it's you have to put your
ego aside and also just suck it up
you're going have to give Equity away
but then the percentage that we keep
will be worth way more down the line
because the business will grow and
accelerate quicker M um and just a touch
on that we put a um and same thing this
year with foundations we released an Emi
scheme for the team right so at the
moment it's 10% MH there are triggers
that you get uh for a consultant to hit
their 1% quota right I want everybody to
have a percent of the business all the
founding members I remember I know we
short in time but I remember a story um
I was in a I went for lunch or dinner
with a client in Dallas they just sold a
private Equity Firm it's one of the ones
we've done a talent as a service for I
think it Sol like just on 300 million
and um I said what was like how do it
make you feel and he was like uh just
like yeah is and he's ex US Marine right
so he's like I don't really care about
the money even though rocked up in like
an all blacked out Aston Martin um but
he said the best feeling was 13 of their
founding members instantly overnight
Millionaires and it was like they didn't
come from money and he like then we all
went for a big dinner to celebrate and
it was like oh who's buying a swimming
pool who's who's taking the kids away
for like a once in a lifetime round
World trip and he was like that for him
was like the best feeling in the world
so how do I get that how does Charlie
how do we replicate that cuz that's what
I want for my team um as well as being
better business people better to humans
when we when they come through the kind
of trident machine um it's if you're
with us from the start and you kind of
finish with us then you should be
getting a chunk of change for that
Journey because it's [__] hard right
especially this year love it people
manager marketing Finance chairman from
industry I love that approach and then
also then yeah setting up those types of
things to what is it the long long time
and
um long-term incentive plans yeah yeah
those types of things right to think
about and this is you know you guys
growing up as a business we gr scaling
and it's I like the analogy of that
visualizing AA and like building you
could have just over every time you add
on to the top which is a new consultant
bricks getting taken out the bottom
unless you've got a really strong
Foundation there which is your people
marketing Finance love that Josh been a
pleasure mate love your energy really
excited to to see where Trident is over
the next couple of years thanks for
coming on the Pod mate appreciate thanks
mate